hey guys welcome to the first patreon q
a on this channel
where today i'll be answering a bunch of
questions that you guys submitted
these q a's will be happening around two
times a month possibly more if we get
more and more patrons
so if you want to get your questions in
for the next one then just be sure to
chip in on patreon and support me in the
transition
to becoming a full-time content creator
you can support from as small as two
dollars a month
so if you want to get involved then
click the link in my description or my
pinned comment
i want these videos to be more of a
conversation than my regular content
so i intentionally didn't look at the
vast majority of these questions
just so that i could give you like my
initial immediate reaction but with that
said
be sure to subscribe and let's get into
it the first question comes from chronos
gw
who asks how hurt is hawks right now
will he heal a hundred percent with time
is he fatally injured somewhere in
between um so this is a really
interesting question
based on the latest chapter that we saw
when hawkes was involved
it seemed like the whole just the
entirety of his wings had been burned
off
my immediate reaction was he will never
recover and i know that may sound a bit
drastic but
we have to consider that hawks has a
mutation quirk right so when you have a
mutation quirk it's basically like
having an additional limb
so when we look at odro for example like
i'm sure if you cut off his tail it
wouldn't grow back
in the same way that if you cut off a
normal person's arm it wouldn't grow
back
the one exception i see to this was
tenure because i remember during the
joint training arc he like removed his
engines and then they grew back which
was a really interesting case for a
mutation quirk
but i would assume in hawks's case that
likely wouldn't happen
dabi seems to have completely just
burned off everything so
not just the feathers but the wings
themselves and so if dabi is completely
burned off not just the feathers but
also the wings themselves like the bone
um i don't see how hawks is ever gonna
fly again uh and
just to back that up a little bit more
tokiyami when he arrived to help hawks
he you know i think it was dark shadow
did in fact say that
everything was gone just his whole back
had been burnt up so debbie really
didn't you know show hawks any mercy
in answer to your main question you know
like i said i do not think hawks is
going to be coming back
uh sorry his quirk is going to be coming
back unless there's some
incredible plot armor that's about to
just uh appear out of nowhere
um or potentially erie you know she's
the go-to for you know
if we ever have a problem like this it's
always oh yeah eric can fix it so yeah
maybe every will come in at some point
but naturally i do not see hawks's wings
growing back i'll be very surprised if
that happens
but obviously i'll be happy if it
happens because i do like hawks a lot
the next question comes from another
pointless who says
any recommendations on anime you're
watching or manga you're reading
so um yeah i have quite a few
recommendations actually the main thing
that comes to mind was dr stone i
watched the first season of that
and uh i say this with no reservation it
was the first anime i've ever watched
that actually made me shed like real
tears um that season finale man oh my
god it was just
it was just amazing um so yeah i really
like dr stone a lot
and i plan you know when i start doing
this full time anyway
um i plan to cover a lot more series
including dr stone
but in terms of what i'm catching up on
right now i can recommend a few manga
so mashel is a manga that i've been
reading week to week and i really like
it
um time paradox ghostwriter as well like
that story
is a very very interesting i would
definitely recommend it
just to give you a really brief summary
um it's about a guy who wants to be a
mangaka who's someone who
you know illustrates manga and
everything's just been going wrong his
whole life
and one day you know something
incredible happens and the story just
takes a crazy
time travel turn honestly amazing so i
would recommend i would recommend
reading that
um definitely but in terms of what else
i'm watching
jojo's bizarre adventure um is something
that i've been watching recently
everyone in my comments like i always
see like people asking me if certain
things were a jojo reference
and i just want to reply like no it's
not a judge a reference because i've
never seen it
i am watching it because everyone hypes
it up a lot and
um being completely honest i'm really
enjoying part two
part one was very bizarre um as you
would expect but
i don't really like part one as much but
part two i'm seriously enjoying it
um this isn't spoilers because this has
been out for like
eight years i believe um but caesar just
died in part two where i'm at
and oh my god it was that was
heartbreaking that was heartbreaking if
i was gonna cry i would have credited
that
um but yeah yeah i'm really enjoying
judges right now
and um yeah that's all i have for now
but i do have other series i'm planning
to catch up on
um for example demonstrator i watched
the first episode of that um and i was
reading it a little bit as well but i
put it on the back burner
because it didn't hook me in the way i
assumed it would because of all the hype
but
i'll get back to it don't you worry
stephen lopez asks
do you think shiguraki will revive twice
um
quick answer to that no i don't think
that will happen twice's death happened
for a reason
obviously it's a great benefit for the
heroes for him not to be in the game
and also i think his death will cause
toga to take certain actions
going into this next part of the arc
because if you notice
as soon as twice died togo went on a
crazy rampage
killing a ton of heroes so her
demeanor has completely changed from one
that's kind of like
happy go lucky you know evil villain to
one that's like
i'm gonna kill every hero i see um which
is very different
so no i think his death will remain
permanent and it's pretty
necessary because the way shigaraki is
looking right now i mean
if twice did come back shigaraki you
know you could have two sugar keys or
more
that would just be too overpowered so it
wouldn't be good it wouldn't be good if
it happened
and i don't even think shiguraki has the
capability to revive twice a
resurrection quirk
would be a bit too op especially
considering all the ones he has
so uh yeah i'm gonna say no chronos gw
says i loved your video with rico
fajardo is there any plans to land
future guests and if so
is there any update at this time as to
who slash when it might be
um so yeah first of all thank you for
watching that because that was the
longest video on my channel by a mile
but i really loved interviewing rico
he's such a cool guys
anyone who's seen the interview will
know um i have a bit of a funny story
about
that so when i initially messaged recall
on twitter to say like do you want to do
an interview
i literally like less than a thousand
subscribers and he agreed to it and i
was not expecting that because obviously
you know less than a thousand
subscribers isn't really the biggest
channel in the world um and he agreed to
it
and then by the time we ended up getting
around to it the channel had 20 000
subscribers it had been like a month and
a half
and in that space of time the channel
just blew up that that whole month was
just a crazy time of growth for the
channel
um but he's such a cool guy in terms of
who
i'm looking to interview in the future i
do want to interview more people
in my head i'm thinking probably rico
himself in the future
although i haven't asked him yet but i'm
sure in the future he'll be down
and i i want to interview xeno robinson
as well the guy who voices hawks in the
english dub
um he seems really cool on twitter and
hawks is just awesome
so those are two people i have in my
mind for the future although
in terms of when it might be i'm
thinking most likely
earliest october 2020 if it's gonna
happen i reckon i will
lay the lay the foundations for october
or slightly later than that
but yeah i'm excited to do it again for
sure
steven brinkley asks knowing that it's
virtually impossible to ever atone for
the abuse of children
in spite of his redemption is it likely
that endeavour will be killed
how do you see that going i believe that
derby will kill him as his identity is
revealed and shoto will be in proximity
to witness the murder
as endeavour pays the ultimate price for
his past with shoto growing an
attachment to his redeemed father
do you think we will see a rage induced
shoto
or a sympathetic one due to knowing
debbie's identity and what he endured
that is re that is a really good
question um
you know what there's kind of two sides
to this because during the endeavor
agency arc we saw
what a great teacher endeavor was and
i'm just thinking about when the
villains win because they are gonna win
um when the villains take over endeavour
would be almost a perfect teacher for
this next generation of pro heroes
um so i think it would be quite
important for endeavor to survive
that said the scenario that you
presented with endeavour being killed by
darby
uh and then shot her witnessing it that
would be almost perfect
it would be almost poetic if that
happened one problem though
that be in his current state cannot kill
endeavour i'm just being straight up
like
those two go head to head endeavor is
gonna win every time
um dabi just doesn't have the stamina
the durability within his own body to
maintain that
so if my theory about him potentially
getting a regeneration quirk from
sugaraki
if that happens then yeah sure maybe
debbie can win
but in ordinary circumstances i do not
see that happening
you could argue that because endeavour
has already been exhausted from fighting
shigeraki
and by the time dabi gets there maybe
endeavour is just really worn out and
darby just kills him
that that could happen i suppose that is
that would be realistic
shoto will be pissed off if endeavour
gets killed um and i don't think he's
going to be sympathetic to darby
i don't think so um because dabby is a
villain dabi kidnapped bakugo
dabi you know even though darby's his
brother dabi still tried to kill shoto
like
we forget during the forest training
camp arc dabby uh
sent a blast of blue flames straight
towards deku and shoto was right there
he was mocking shoto when he kidnapped
bakugo so yeah i don't think there's
gonna be any brother
brotherly love there especially as they
probably were not that close
another pointless axe most likely hero
or villain to die next
and how um so yeah coming off the back
of the last chapter
it would seem that mina is in a bit of a
tricky situation right now right
she's charging headfirst at
gigantomachia she's gonna throw the
capsule in there to put him to sleep
and one thing i have to remind you guys
every time in this war arc when it looks
like the heroes are gonna do something
positive
it always flips around and turns into a
negative right
every single time whether it's when they
invaded the mansion
you know for several chapters it looked
like it was going well
until it wasn't and with the invasion of
jakku hospital
you know they get in there it looks like
they're going to stop shigeraki for a
second it looked like shiguraki was dead
and then oh you know oh crap he's alive
he destroys our whole city
so like every time he looks positive it
always turns into a negative
so the fact that mina is standing right
in front of gigantomachia
she's going to throw the capsule in
she's going to try and put him to sleep
next chapter
she could die like it can literally flip
like that
and it's been like it's been like this
whole arc so far it just flips
so mina is in a really tricky situation
uh i hope she doesn't die because she's
a very uh important character to me i
mean she's not like
one of the main characters but it would
be very significant if she died of all
students
if they kill someone irrelevant like
invisible girl i would not care
for the most part i would not care um so
yeah i just gotta say
mina right now looks like she's on the
chopping block
but um if i depict someone else maybe
izawa
uh although i actually don't think he's
gonna die this arc but the the
the flags are there if he was going to
die it's all there
but i actually personally think he will
not die because people have died to save
him right cross died to save izawa
so to then kill izawa after that is kind
of like oh okay you've killed two people
uh for no reason so i feel like
isabella's life has meaning
and there's a reason he's still alive
and didn't die back then when cross
saved him
so we're just gonna see we're just gonna
see what happens next chronos gw
arcs most underrated episode for me this
one is easily bakago versus ochaco
in season 2. yeah that was a really
great episode especially with the whole
twist of ochako
with the meteor shower i really liked
that when i first saw it but um no in
terms of my most underrated episode
it would have to be the one just before
all might
and all for one start fighting again uh
and the reason i say that is because
it was almost like a three-part episode
right there was there was the initial
episode where they did the raid
um and saved bakugo then there was the
middle episode where all for one and all
might fight
and then there was the end episode where
all my wins and i feel like because it
had the least amount of action
the first part of those three episodes
was just i'm assuming
i would assume it would be underrated
because it wasn't as epic as the others
but um i really like that first episode
when they saved back ago
and then all for one just flipped the
switch all the gnomers come bursting in
oh man that was an
epic moment um yeah i'm gonna say i'm
gonna say that one
stephen lopez asks do you think the
million will get his quirk back and when
so i did a video on this like uh about
five months ago now i reckon
and uh in short i do think the million
will eventually get his quirk back
and i see it happening one of two ways
first way
the most obvious way every rewinds him
and i say that's the most obvious
because mario and eri have a very close
relationship
and obviously as time progresses her
power progresses her control of the
quirk progresses
so it's possible that within a couple of
years she is within our capabilities to
rewind him back
comfortably where there's no risk of him
being rewound out of existence
so that's probably the most likely
scenario however there is
a second scenario and that is that if we
remember tamaki got hit with a prototype
version of the quirk destroying bullet
and then his quirk came back after a day
so it took a day to wear off right
muriel got hit with the supposedly
perfected version of the bullet
but how do we know that's the perfected
version like
they might call it that but how do they
know that it's permanent
it's possible that within a couple of
years maybe five years maybe 10 years
the quirk will come back in the same way
it came back for tamaki
um that's just my two cents although i
think yes the most likely way is erie
rewinding him
stefan brinkley says if this theory were
to come true and he's talking about the
bakago being the second user
of one floor theory uh he says if this
theory were to come true
how would aries quirk have to either be
revealed to work
or how would her quirk have to evolve
based on the definitions of rewind
the current overhaul explanation doesn't
seem quite right because based off his
description of her quirk
her quirk would be called regress so
curious about this
in terms of how it could be evolved i
mean there's so many
there's so many ways right what we've
seen from erie so far is that she's able
to rewind
human beings and also she's able to
rewind animals as well because
during overhauls experiments he rewound
some rats
so it can rewind living things right and
over time yes i do think she will be
able to rewind
um not just people not just animals but
also
uh inanimate objects now the whole
purpose of that
back ago second user theory was that
erie gets trigger
and the i guess the aim of that was that
erie could rewind
literally space time itself so
if you're standing there she can
literally rewind the space around you
essentially rewind that space so when
she's done you're going to be
in that same spot just in a different
time that was the whole theory
um in terms of how a cult would have to
evolve well
training is the is the way that anyone's
quirk evolves shigeraki's work didn't
just evolve out of nowhere he was
battling gagantomachia for a really long
period of time
which then enabled him to you know grow
his quirk um
same for the rest of the league of
villains toga as well so
with star with thorough training erie
can potentially get to that level
another point that says any further
thoughts on you a traitor
i saw some theories about chapter 259
where you can't see her gakurei
she's invisible yeah she is invisible
maybe that's why
um but then in chapter 264 you see the
same group
but then she's there all of a sudden i
still think it's out of hagakurei or
koda
interesting thought you know what if the
uh traitor was someone like hugakurei
uh invisible girl that would be really
lame i'm going to be honest
that would that would be harakoshi
fumbling the bag right there because
if it's going to be someone that we have
virtually no emotional connection to
how is it going to how is it going to be
of impact it will be of impact to the
students sure they'll be shocked
but like we as an audience will we truly
like we truly care if it's just an
irrelevant side character
in my opinion if it's going to be a
student it has to be someone that we
care about
so someone like for example mina someone
who's you know we know them we just
don't see them all the time
um i think i think would have to be at
the least someone like that
um coda you know coda is is is just
we don't even see this man so so no i
think ultimately
it will have to be someone that we have
a connection to when the uh traitor
reveals their identity
uh it will be an iconic moment for the
series but hopefully made more iconic by
the fact
that it's a character we actually care
about stefan lopez asks
what's your favorite episode so far um
that's a really hard question man
you know what i i if there was an
episode that i could re-watch at any
time
it would be victory or defeat so that
was an episode from season two when deku
faces off against shinzo
in the sports festival that is an
episode i can watch anytime i
bought it on itunes it's the only
episode i've bought on itunes because i
love that episode
so much but is it the best episode in
the series ever
probably not but it's the one that i can
rewatch almost at any time
um but you know what mate my favorite
episode is yet to come because i know
it's coming in season six when this war
arc is animated
um so we'll see check ask me that
question in two years
and i'll give you a very different
answer if you've made it this far in the
video i want to thank you so much for
watching
um and also shout out to chronos gw
right because he submitted
a ton of questions for me i really
appreciate it i just didn't want to make
the video too long so i didn't answer
all of them
but uh thank you so much for your
questions mate and we'll probably get to
quite a few of them in the next one as
well um but yeah if you want to support
the channel like i said i'm planning on
transitioning to becoming
a full-time content creator and so i
need your guys support on patreon you
know whether it's two dollars a month
you can give whether it's five dollars
every little counts um because there are
strengthened numbers my friends there is
strength in numbers
and until the next one guys peace out